- I’m Lionel Messi. I let my football speak for itself.
- I should have played for the Spanish team.
- I learned that I’m more like a Messi type,
like, uh, let my football do the talking, you know.
- I’m the best in La Liga, b---h!
- I’m better than you with two broken elbows!
- Oh yeah? I got the trophy this year, b---h!
- How about you pay your taxes and then we talk, b---h!
- Barcelona, we didn’t mean to put you front and centre
but, unfortunately, all the corners were taken too quickly.
- I’m very happy for Luka that he won the Ballon d’Or.
- But mainly that Ronaldo didn’t win.
- It’s my job to make sure that all the players on the team are happy
like, I’ve noticed that Messi has been a bit down since the World Cup.
- Hey, you guys. Sorry Gareth bailed.
Thanks for taking the rest of us out.
- Now you are just like your season...
Totally wasted!
- Football is in my veins.
- Also, growth hormones.
- Dear Cristiano,
we had so many happy Clasico’s together.
This will always be how I remember you.
- What is this?!
Noooo. Lionel, you dog!
- Suck on my balls.
- Man, I haven’t seen Leo this frustrated since
after every single international tournament.
- I don’t call them free-kicks.
- I call them free goals.
- They say I should ask Ronaldo to dinner
because he is the only person who understands,
you know, how it feels to always be around
worse players.
- So, are you excited?
- Um...no.
- Can I get a little help here?
I can’t do this by myself.
- We are not the same. OK, I am a brand...
and you are just like a...um...a football robot or something.
- Yeah, run away like you ran away from La Liga...
p---y ass b---h!
- What did you just say?
- We are Messi.
It is our fate.
When we’re not blowing three-goal leads, we are great.
Oh, we are Messi.
It’s time to show.
That we are so much better than Cristiano.
- Sucks.
- Ladies and gentlemen, my wife Shakira.
- [yodeling]
Football.
- I will not promote this cartoon.
- But I will!
Subscribe to B/R Football to support ‘The Champions.’